why
so Civil War issue number five is a very
exciting comic book in the Civil War
series and the reason for this is
because up until this comic book you
know throughout all the times that we've
seen throughout Civil War frontline and
even the main comic book account civil
war stories we've really kind of seen
this gradual build-up we've really kind
of seen seen this gradual increase and
we really kind of were given this
indication that at the end of all this
there would be some major conflict that
would take place but it really kind of
seemed to drag on it really kind of
seemed to be that Marvel was really
providing us with more dialogue and more
character development than actual action
I mean we had seen action here and there
we especially saw action when we saw the
whole conflict and the destruction of
the Yancy Street area and the thing
leaving the country and so on and so
forth but Civil War issue number five
really kind of hits the ground running
we're with previous Civil War issues we
really kind of slowly built into it
civil war issue number five jumps off
extremely fast and what we see here is
if you recall Civil War issue number
four we had talked about how Susan storm
had left Reed Richard she had left his
side left Iron Man's side as part of the
pro registration movement and Johnny
Storm was really kind of coming to
Johnny Storm was really kind of coming
out of his coma coming out of his
injuries and really kind of healing and
so what we see is that Johnny Storm and
Sue Storm are of course side by side
with one another and they are on the
side of Captain America and they're
attempting to escape shield now what we
see is that after trying to get away of
course Johnny Storm tells Sue Storm to
make them invisible and shield of course
adapts to this power adapts to her
ability to make anybody invisible by
using infrared and this is really kind
of important because by them using
infrared of course they can track them
no matter where they go from here we
transition to start tower and again if
you recall Civil War issue number four
we had talked about how after the death
of Goliath there would be a kind of
changing of the guard where people would
leave both sides some people would leave
Ironman
side and go to Captain America side and
some people would leave Captain America
side and go to Ironman side and while we
saw that Sue Storm had left the side of
Ironman and how Johnny Storm had left
the side of Ironman to join Captain
America side we see that Nighthawk and
stature are leaving Captain America side
to join Ironman side now they're meeting
with happy Hogan here and of course
happy Hogan is the right-hand man of
Tony Stark and has been for quite some
time but it's really kind of an
interesting scenario here because under
normal circumstances they would be
meeting with Tony Stark and happy Hogan
really kind of takes a note of this and
says that Tony Stark should have been
here by now and it's a little strange
that he hasn't been and what we do is we
really kind of transition to the
upstairs portion of stark tower and we
see the Tony Stark and Peter Parker are
fighting one another and again to tie
back into civil war
issue number four we had seen meta and
even with issue number three that Peter
Parker was really kind of developing
these early feelings of questioning
whether or not Tony Stark was right
whether or not superhuman registration
was really the way to go and where we
had previously talked about Peter Parker
really kind of developing these feelings
and that it would evolve into something
more we really kind of see this coming
to fruition we see that Peter Parker for
the most part is rebelling against Tony
Stark that he doesn't want to be part of
this anymore that he thinks that it's
wrong that he thinks that what's going
on here is something that doesn't need
to happen because the idea of locking
superheroes in the negative zone with no
real trial the idea of unleashing a
clone of Thor a cyborg that resulted in
the death of a fellow superhero is
pretty much something that really
indicates this has gone far to gone on
far too long and that shield and Iron
Man are simply just in over their heads
what we also see is a little bit of
discussion here a little bit of
rationale on both sides of them and an
Iron Man is really kind of interesting
here because again we get a little more
in-depth we get a little more discussion
here in terms of what Iron Man's
perspective is on this that Iron Man
believes that the problem is that if
superheroes are not regulated if
superheroes are not registered that this
will lead to some kind of huge problem
it'll lead to some kind of huge crisis
and
ultimately it will lead to the
government really kind of regulating all
superheroes there will really not be any
kind of a better system here will simply
be that some superheroes are registered
if they choose to be and those that
don't will be arrested it'll simply be
that the government will ban all
superheroes everywhere and so this is
really kind of the the best scenario
again we really kind of see that a Peter
Parker and Captain I'm sorry that Iron
Man begin to come to blows again and
Iron Man really kind of says this is for
the greater good he says it's not just
about you he says what about on May what
about Mary Jane and and Peter Parker
says that that they're as far away as
possible they are as safe as you can
possibly make them and then this is
really kind of when Tony Stark realizes
that there's no coming back for Peter
Parker that Peter Parker is in no way
going to really kind of change his mind
that he is now irrevocably against the
superhuman Registration movement and
Ironman goes as far as to say that he's
disappointed in this and Peter Parker of
course responds by saying that he's not
nearly as disappointed and I'm sorry the
Tony Succar is not nearly as
disappointed in Peter Parker as Peter
Parker is and himself from here we see
Peter Parker try to escape but of course
the glass is reinforced and then we see
shield arrive now initially Iron Man
really kind of tries to stop shield from
shooting at Peter Parker not necessarily
because he doesn't want to see
spider-man killed but because if the
glass is destroyed then Peter Parker
will be able to escape and of course as
a result of a shield coming in and
firing at Peter Parker they destroy the
glass and Peter Parker is able to get
away we see that as a response to this
because Peter Parker spider-man is now
able to escape and he's not now kind of
out on his own that Maria Hill activates
the new Thunderbolts protocol and if you
recall again our discussion about the
previous Civil War events we had talked
about how the Baron Zemo led group of
the Thunderbolts had really kind of gone
away but some of those members stayed
along and when they stayed they became
part of the new Thunderbolts arrangement
that was set up by by shields so of
course we see individuals like
taskmaster taskmaster we see Lady
Deathstrike we see venom we see various
individuals who had previously been
supervillains now fighting on behalf of
federal government and this is something
that will become very very important
especially when we get into Civil War
issue number six and what we see is that
of course spider-man is underground now
spider-man is actually literally
underground and is really kind of trying
to figure out what to do next trying to
figure out what his next move is and
then we see that he's confronted by a
couple super villains who are members of
the Thunderbolts who of course are now
released and are tasked with the goal of
finding a spider-man we see that he's
confronted by Jack O'Lantern and by
gesture
now these villains weren't necessarily
major villains in the realm of Marvel
Comics as a whole these are really kind
of villains that were confined as
spider-man colleagues but they were very
formidable villains nonetheless Jack
O'Lantern was in a lot of ways kind of a
spinoff of the Green Goblin and jester
was really kind of a spin-off of I guess
maybe a combination of the Joker from DC
Comics and the Green Lantern I'm sorry
the Green Goblin from Marvel Comics we
see that for the most part Peter Parker
is really kind of caught unawares and
because of the fact that both of these
villains are formidable in their own
right there really isn't a whole lot
that Peter Parker can do against the
both of them their intention after they
pretty much have kind of defeated him is
to kill him but of course shield tells
him tells these individuals to stand
down of course they report that they
have Peter Parker captured and while
shield is on their way to I guess to
attain or to take Peter Parker into
custody we see that Jack O'Lantern is
killed in addition we don't really know
who it was that did this we simply know
that someone is standing there and that
someone has effectively rendered both
the Jester and Jack O'Lantern dead more
or less that they've basically killed
them but what we see is that Peter
Parker really kind of responds to this
and says that I know your face you're
that skull-faced guy and this is really
kind of an indication to us that this is
Frank Castle The Punisher
now from here we again switch back to
Susan storm and Johnny storm and we see
that they have new disguises and again
they kind of poke fun at the idea that
Nick Fury had given them these kind of
disguises that were a little strange and
this
that they're actually together now that
they are masquerading as husband and
wife which is a little strange
considering that they're brother and
sister but the idea of Nick Fury and the
civil war event is really kind of
intriguing here and I think it's
important that we touch on this the
silver the Civil War of then is of
course one of the major events and
Marvel Comics and we don't see Nick Fury
here we see Nick Fury hinted at we see
Nick Fury discussed but we don't
actually really see Nick Fury proper in
the sense that we see him talking to
everybody else in person and the reason
for this is because there is a much
larger and far more I guess maybe
catastrophic event that's coming up in
Marvel Comics after the Civil War that
Nick Fury is really kind of uncovered
that he's really found the beginnings of
and so Nick Fury is really kind of off
dealing with this while simultaneously
doing the best he can to aid those
individuals who are underground that are
on Captain America's side from here of
course we see that a Susan storm and
Johnny Storm arrive at Captain America's
hideout Atta in Queens I believe and we
really kind of get a little more detail
on some of the characters that we
haven't seen just yet of course we see
them talking about cloak and dagger and
about how they had been captured and we
see that at Captain America is a little
frustrated here because they're
essentially losing one man for every
person that they gain and so they're
really not making any ground in terms of
being able to match the numbers that are
on the side of Tony Stark now this next
section is extremely important because
what we see is that hoechlin who is a
shapeshifter
and a member of the Young Avengers
offers to impersonate a staff of the
Baxter building and to gain the I guess
maybe the security blueprints for the
the back ship building itself but we see
that Captain America declines this offer
in tells him that he has a much bigger
job for him in Arizona in addition we
see that he gives the task of of going
to I guess another another goal of some
sort to the Invisible Woman now we will
see what the the tasks are that Captain
America gives to these individuals but
we won't learn about them until Civil
War issue number six and so I would like
you to pay very close attention to
really kind of keep this in
the back of your heads because these two
things will become very important in
addition we see that as they're
conversing as they're talking the
Punisher enters holding Peter Parker and
he really kind of tells Captain America
or somebody in general that they need to
get a medic so they can tend to Peter
Parker and what we kind of see here is
that Captain America calls for Jane
Foster to assist Peter Parker and to
really kind of tend to his medical
injuries to really kind of tend to the
injuries that he sustained as a result
of fighting both gesture and
jack-o-lantern in addition we really
kind of see the group discussing what to
do with Frank Castle they're really not
sure what side he's on maybe he's on the
side of Captain America maybe he's on
the side of Iron Man and Falcon goes as
far as to ask the question you know
which side are you on here in addition
we see that Frank Castle chose the side
of Captain America because Ironman has
allied himself with supervillains and
this is not something that we've seen
Captain America do yet
Iron Man really chose to ally himself
only insofar that he would use the
Thunderbolts as a means to an end but
Captain America has not chosen this road
now whether or not this is a road that
Captain America chose because he simply
didn't want to have anything to do with
villains or because he just simply
didn't have access to him is not
necessarily something that we've been
given yet and I don't think that he
actually goes in a detail about this in
addition they're really kind of debating
as to whether or not they should allow
Frank castle to stay a part of their
group and what we learn here is that if
you recall in Civil War issue number
four we had talked about how when
Nighthawk and others were leaving a
Captain America's team that there was a
masked individual that was watching over
everything now the initial indication
and I think the Marvel kind of played on
this was that this individual may have
been crossbones we didn't really know
who he was but then we learned that it
was actually Frank Castle and the Frank
Castle had in the background and in the
shadows kept multiple individuals off
the scent of Captain America's team and
it really kind of bailed them out of
scenarios where they normally would have
been captured albeit doing it with kind
of a hidden hand and so people are
really kind of hesitant about Frank
Castle they're really kind of unsure
about Frank castle because Frank Castle
enigma and marvel comics we know about
him but we don't really know what it is
at he'll do he is kind of like Deadpool
in a lot of ways Frank Castle has a
moral code and Frank castles code says
that he kills villains everywhere no
matter what they're doing but we don't
necessarily know whether or not he's in
a stable state of mind we don't know if
he is sane at this point in time because
a large portion of the superhero
community considers him to be insane now
Luke Cage of course asks him do we want
to keep Frank Castle here and Captain
America simply says that he's thinking
but what we also see is that while all
these individuals are meeting someone is
kind of hidden in a corner and is
recording the entire event now from here
we see that daredevil has been captured
in Hell's Kitchen and he's being taken
away by shield but he's also kind of
being escorted by by Reed Richards but
before the I guess the transportation
vehicle leaves for presumably the
negative zone we really kind of see Reed
Richards talking with she-hulk and this
is really kind of interesting here
because for the most part we've never
really seen an instance so far where
Reed Richards is really kind of
questioning this whole superhuman
Registration thing and and he's really
not questioning this so far in the sense
that he regrets getting involved he's
really just kind of questioning the
motives and really kind of questioning
the end result here of course Reed
Richards has used mathematical
probability to determine the fact that
this is the most rational course of
action but again it really doesn't
doesn't have swayed his guilty
conscience
because for the most part there really
isn't anyone in his family on his corner
in his corner anymore
Susan storm Johnny Storm they've left
for the side of Captain America the
thing has left for Paris he's not in the
United States anymore and so all that
Reed Richards really has is valaria
Richards and Franklin Richards
and their kids they really don't
understand the stake the the
ramifications of what's going on at this
point in time and we see him really kind
of I guess discussing with she-hulk his
thoughts he's really kind of talking to
her about how things are going he's
really kind of saying he's not really
sure about what's going on here but she
really kind of ass wages this and says
that they've given them a future they've
given them the chance to continue their
role is
superheroes rather than allowing this
kind of fear on behalf of society and
the perception of superheroes bubble up
to a point where it just kind of leads
to this place where all superheroes are
outlawed entirely